diablement je reviens au roi il a pris
un risque énorme et r non il a pris
beaucoup de retard c'est frileux celle
ci c'est comme vous dites très bien
c'est inédit il a c'est la première fois
qu'il prend une position aussi ferme
même depuis 75 ans n'avait jamais vu un
cette dynastie se poser au pti aussi
fortement dans le dans la question
nationale mais c'est beaucoup trop tard
c'est mal c'est mal embouché cette
histoire depuis le début avec ccc
premier sondage vous ne comprendrez
peut-être né mi mai ces premiers
sondages qui montraient que finalement
la réalité la catalogne c'est qu'ils
sont pas indépendantiste qui sont à 40 %
voilà quarante deux pour cent donc c'est
l'espoir celui qui font aller en nombre
dimanche votée il est allé en plus sur
les ramblas en outre à août après cet
attentat dramatique et lorsque la grande
avenue de barcelone a eu lieu cet
attrait il ya une quinzaine de morts
quand même donc il peut beaucoup de
blessés donc il a fait quand même un
chef très fort à ce moment là il n'a pas
pris position il a pas pris il n'a pas
eu une parole forte sur cette histoire
politique mais c'était peut-être pas le
moment et ensuite le 11 septembre cette
grande fête nationale entre guillemets
catalan a été l'occasion d'une
démonstration de force dans la rue qui
laissaient présager les séquences
suivantes et je trouve que là ya pas eu
assez de force dans le discours du roi
donc il arrive bien sûr il arrive
maintenant mais il arrive un peu tard
j'ai l'impression que il a un peu raté
la séquence et je dirais que la séquence
avait raté depuis à mon avis la reprise
en 78 à mon avis il n'y a pas une la
pensée sur la nation espagnole après le
franquisme jamais parce qu'ils sont
tellement enrichi dans les années 80-90
chacun allait s'enrichir penser à son
propre destin individuel et depuis la
crise de 2008 a tous essayé tous ces
éléments this to c est toutes ces
velléités de récupérer 7 7 catalogne
riche quand même qui gagne 20 % du pib
national et c est bien ça ça se crispe à
ce qu'il n'y a jamais eu de réflexion
c'était c'était vraiment au roi de faire
ça je pense à son père à juan carlos de
mener 7 cette vraie discussion sur ces
17 provinces autonomes espagnoles
comment on les agrège comment on les
harmonies comment comment on pompe
permet que c'est le problème c'est que
l'idée de bagnols était à tord ou à
raison associés aux nationalistes de
franco est peut-être aussi pour ça qu'il
ya eu 7
cette frilosité